en janvier dernier le président russe
surprend tout le monde en proposant
d'apporter des amendements à la
constitution
quelques heures après cette annonce le
gouvernement décide de démissionner la
constitution actuelle date de 1993 et a
été mise en place sous boris elstine
élaboré sur les décombres de l'ère
soviétique
elle est l'objet de critiques dues à
l'hyper présidentialisation du jeu
politique qu'elle induit c'est aussi une
constitution qui n'est dans le sang à
l'époque le parlement contrôlé par les
communistes hostiles au projet tente de
destituer helsinn pour rester au pouvoir
il fait appel à l'armée 187 personnes
sont tuées durant cet automne
l'un des objectifs principaux de ce
changement de constitution et donc de
mettre fin à ce système tout en
conservant intactes les bases de la
constitution à l'heure actuelle seul le
président peut nommer le chef du
gouvernement et les ministres le
parlement donne juste son feu vert
formel le changement proposé renforcera
le pouvoir du parlement qui aura le
dernier mot concernant la composition du
gouvernement tandis que le président ne
sera pas en mesure de s'y opposer les
pouvoirs seront ainsi redistribués entre
les différentes branches afin
d'équilibrer le système de gouvernance
russe un autre changement important
porte sur la limitation des mandats
présidentiels à deux au total au lieu de
deux mandats consécutifs actuellement
cela implique que les futurs chefs
d'état ne pourront pas rester au pouvoir
aussi longtemps que vladimir poutine
un changement qui obnubile les médias
occidentaux selon les règles existantes
à vladimir poutine doit partir dans
quatre ans à la fin de son second mandat
consécutif
son quatrième au total les membres du
parlement ont néanmoins proposé de
remettre à zéro le compteur de ses
mandats avec des amendements
je propose soit de lever la limitation
du nombre de mandats présidentiels soin
d'inclure dans un article du projet de
loi une clause permettant au président
actuel
une fois que la constitution modifiée
sera entrée en vigueur de se porter
candidat à l'élection présidentielle
comme à tout autre citoyen cela signifie
que poutine pourra se porter candidat en
2024 et en 2030 s'ils le souhaitent
pour vladimir poutine ces changements
dans la constitution vise à mettre en
place un état providence ces amendements
seront adoptées seulement si la cie la
population donne son assentiment
est ce qu'à ce moment là ce ne pourront
poursuivre le développement dynamique de
la cie les amendements sont adoptés
cela permettra deux fils et un niveau
plus élevé de responsabilité sociale de
responsabilité vis-à-vis de l'ensemble
du pays
il y à plus de 140 amendements l'un de
garantie que le salaire minimum ne peut
pas être inférieur au coût de la vie un
autre changement consacre la primauté du
droit russe sur le droit international
certaines propositions font l'objet de
débats par exemple le mariage sera
uniquement considérée comme l'union
entre un homme et une femme dieu sera
également mentionné même si la russie
restera un état laïque est des
propositions qui sont soumises à un
référendum
les modifications seront donc adopter
uniquement si les citoyens russes les
approuvent